We have previously studied
the translational motion
of rigid bodies by analyzing the
motion of their center of mass.
We have also studied the
rotation of rigid bodies
about a fixed axis.
This week, we will consider
more complicated examples
of rigid body motion, where
translation and rotation are
both occurring simultaneously.
One example is, if I toss a
rigid body through the air
but give it a spin
at the same time
so that it tumbles
in space as it falls.
A second example
is a wheel that is
rolling along a flat surface.
Its location is translating,
but at the same time,
it is also spinning
about its axis.
A natural way to
analyze such motions
is to, once again,
take advantage
of [? Chasles' ?]
theorem, which states
that one possible
way of describing
the general motion
of a rigid body
is by a translation
of its center of mass
plus a rotation about
its center of mass.
This separation of
the general case
into two distinct
type of motions
will greatly simplify
our analysis.
One of the most common examples
of simultaneous translational
and rotational motion is
that of rolling objects,
and we will concentrate on
this particular application.
We will see that an important
detail is whether or not
the object rolls
without slipping,
and the role that friction
can play in each case.
The special case of
rolling without slipping
amounts to a
constraint condition
that relates the translational
speed of the center of mass
to the radius and the
rotational angular velocity.